-Guys, as I said earlier,
the biggest football game
of the season
is happening on Sunday night,
when Tom Brady
and the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
head to Foxborough
to take on his old team,
the New England Patriots.
Now, as you know, they end
every season with awards,
like, you know, Most Valuable
Player, stuff like that,
but they also give out awards
during the season.
Did you know that?
-No, I did not.
-Yeah.
I'll show you what I mean.
It's time for
"Tonight Show Superlatives."
Here we go.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-♪ "Tonight Show" ♪
♪ "Superlatives" ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
Our first player
from the Bucs is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's a rare award.
-Yeah, that's very rare.
-Yeah.
Next up from the Bucs is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
He's like, "Hey!
He's wearing --"
-Wha-pssh!
Next up from the Patriots is
rookie quarterback...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"Give me a Pence."
-"Give me another one.
I ain't driving."
[ Laughter ]
Next up from the Bucs is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
What?!
Wow. Wow.
Next up from the Patriots is...
[ Laughter ]
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"That ain't gonna work."
[ Laughter ]
Next from the Patriots is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up from the Patriots is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
I didn't know that was going
to Broadway.
-Hope it goes to Broadway.
-And, finally, from the Bucs,
we have quarterback...
He was voted...
[ Cheering and applause ]
There you go.
Those are your NFL
"Superlatives."